House Democrats say they're rejecting
Republican pressure to formally
authorize their impeachment inquiry
Speaker Nancy Pelosi said last night
that investigators will keep working to
find what she calls a path to the truth
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
the list of officials who are not
cooperating with this inquiry seems to
be growing
it sure is you've now got the Department
of Defense the vice president Mike Pence
and the president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani
all ignoring new deadlines to hand over
documents they say they're not going to
comply with an investigation that
essentially they view as illegitimate
they want a vote formalizing the
impeachment inquiry but for now they're
not going to get one at this time we
will not be having a vote after a
meeting with Democratic members House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi announced that her
position has not changed and a vote is
not required the White House says it's
not cooperating in part because there
hasn't been a vote to formalize this
impeachment inquiry why not hold the
vote and call the White House bluff
we're not here to call Bluffs we're here
to find the truth to pull the
Constitution of the United States this
is not a game for us there was more
dramatic testimony Tuesday this time
from Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
George Kent who says he was told to lay
low after he complained that Rudy
Giuliani's efforts in Ukraine were
undermining u.s. foreign policy texts
and emails indicate Giuliani and two US
diplomats kurt volker and Gordon Sunland
urged Ukrainian officials to investigate
mr. Trump's campaign rival Joe Biden and
his son a message the President
reiterated in a July phone call with his
Ukrainian counterpart we have learned
that call was not in isolation there was
a great deal of preparatory work that
was done before the call Kent told
lawmakers he was instructed to leave
Ukraine policy to the so called three
amigos Volcker Sandland and Secretary of
Energy Rick Perry with evidence mounting
Republicans have dialed back their
defense of the president here's a
newsflash
President Trump is not Jesus instead
they're taking aim at the inquiry itself
blasting it as unfair this is a kangaroo
court at best right now lawmakers will
hear today from Michael McKinley he is a
former top advisor to Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo he served in the State
Department for 37 years and just
resigned last week
Anthony Nancy thank you